brace yourselves Guardians of the Galaxy
fans director James Gunn has a message
that'll leave you teary-eyed his warning
for the third installment is Cosmic and
definitely worth a Groot or two after
years of anticipation director James
Gunn and Marvel Studios have finally
released Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
the Marvel Cinematic universe's Cosmic
group first debuted in 2014 grossing
over 333 million dollars domestically
emerging is one of the franchise's
biggest hits the current iteration of
Guardians is getting the swan song
treatment with volume 3 set to be their
last ride what can fans expect from this
final installment well lots of Tears
according to director James Gunn while
speaking with collider gun T's just how
emotional the final film in the trilogy
would be he set our expectations saying
I know that there's been a lot of people
crying in the screening so I guess
people cry scary is your favorite
Guardian is going to bite the dust don't
worry not all of volume 3's tears are
the result of sadness or grief gun
continued but it's not all sad crying
there's a lot of happy crying in the
movie there's a lot of joy in the film
you know everybody talks about the
emotion and it is emotional but there's
a lot of Joy the film is packed with
emotion at least according to Looper
critic Audrey Fox who praised the
threequel for integrating the
heartbreaking backstory for Rocket
Raccoon Fox written their 7 out of 10
review it does right by all of the
characters giving them the send-offs
they deserve especially rocket who
manages to evoke more of an emotional
response than his little CGI face has
any right to seeing as the equal serves
as a heartfelt goodbye to her favorite
group of Intergalactic Heroes and more
than makes sense if volume 3 is the
longest flick in the franchise the
latest film in the MCU follows the
Guardians on a chaotic mission that sees
them racing against the clock to save
one at their own volume 3 notably
features the reunion of Star-Lord and
Gamora who last shared the screen
together in Avengers end game for fans
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is more
than just a satisfying ending it's a
fitting and triumphant send-off to some
of Marvel's most quirky and colorful
characters audiences gave the film The
much coveted a cinema score all but
proving guns still got the charm and
spectacle he had with the first film
don't kill anyone who gets in our way no
not kill anyone kill a few people kill
no people kill one guy one stupid guy
who no one loves you're just making it
sad well gun and the rest of the crew
are likely basking in the film's
positive reception making the film was
no small task for the creative the
director admitted to the Toronto Sun I
was on edge the whole time I was making
this movie I knew how difficult it was
going to be to balance all of these
different characters and the final-ness
of their stories in this Trilogy so it
was always an uneasy feeling for me Gunn
seems to have knocked it out of the park
especially thanks to the film's extended
run time but how long exactly will
audiences get to spend with Star-Lord
and the rest of the Gang This Time
Around Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
clocks in at 2 hours and 30 minutes
making it one of the longest films in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe it's also
the longest film in the trilogy with
volume 1 and 2 coming in at 2 hours and
one minute and 2 hours and 16 minutes
respectively it makes sense that volume
3 is the longest of the punch
considering it wraps up the Arts first
setup in the 2014 film prior to the
film's release gun made it clear on
deadline's hero Nation Podcast that
volume 3 would be the last splick in the
franchise to feature this current roster
of Heroes while it remains to be seen
when the future holds for the next
generation of films in the franchise
it's all but likely that volume 3 serves
his gun's final Marvel outing now that
he's head honcho at DC Studios audiences
are clearly excited to see gun wrap up
his Trilogy with the film earning 114
million dollars over its opening weekend
at the domestic box office
foreign